good morning from the CBS this morning
Toyota greenroom I'm Dana Jacobson and
I'm here with two guests Gary Vaynerchuk
who is over here to my right
also known as Gary Vee after turning his
father's local liquor store into one of
the first e-commerce platforms for
alcohol in the United States he went on
to create a multi-million dollar digital
advertising agency he's a five-time New
York Times bestselling author and has
more than eight million followers on
social media and no free time now he
also serves I say no no free time
because he also serves on the board for
pencils of promise and this is a
nonprofit that helps build schools for
communities across the globe and this is
our second guest that's where it leads
us pencils of promise CEO Tanya Ramos
thinks both of you think you're having
eyes so give us some sense I gave you a
very basic idea of pencils of promise
but what does pencils of promise do we
are an organization that is building
schools around the world in Ghana Laos
and Guatemala I like to say we started
off as a school build organization what
we've evolved and now we have innovative
programming touching close to 100,000
students around the world Gary what was
it about this organization that made you
say I need to take mine on spare time
and put it here
you know the founder Adam Braun is an
unbelievably dynamic individual and when
we we met over our common interest in
the New York Jets
did they win or lose again um because
there's more up and they win
unfortunately but that's the best part
of it but nonetheless he it was just so
unbelievable for me at this time this
was seven or eight years ago watching
young people start taking a path where
they were in the process of giving even
though they had all these business
opportunities instead of the cliche
thing that I grew up with which is you
go and you build and then you give and
I'm so inspired by that I was also
unbelievably inspired by the fact that
for me it wasn't ironically education
even though I was an immigrant from the
former Soviet Union
it was entrepreneurship that changed the
course of my life however in places like
Laos Guatemala gone there there's
there's clearly a need for what we do as
a stepping stone to a disproportionately
different life and so for me anything
that is an engine that can advance your
happiness is super interesting
and and building actual schools I mean I
don't think just people that are ykt
people that are watching don't
understand their these are kids learning
under a tree because I think a lot of
people don't say well they're kids in
the US that need resources and help so
why are you taking them why are you are
doing this overseas four hundred eighty
nine schools so for those people who say
why are you doing it there it is because
they're learning under a tree
absolutely and because we need to know
that we live in a globally
interconnected world and that every
child regardless of the circumstances
that they're born into regardless of the
issues that they're facing in their
respective country they deserve to be
educated and we want our children around
the globe 250 million children are
unable to read and write and we want to
see that change in our life tie it open
so many doors I mean you think about
there's a basic ability the other way
real quickly I know if I could write a
check for $25,000 and build a school in
America and change the curriculum inside
of it right to actually be valuable in a
20-19 world I would do that too and
that's what it costs over that's 25,000
that's why it's a little more and I know
there's a range there's a range but like
the punchline is that that was where the
checks that I was writing for the first
schools when I joined pop okay making an
impact right the reason you can't do it
in America is because the maturity of
the system and the bureaucracy and
politics that go along with it right and
at least have a difference and make a
difference as you said it's a global
community that we live in you have an
impact there for people that want to
have an impact forget the check for
$25,000 some people maybe can't write a
check
twenty-five dollars is exciting to me I
couldn't be more we have our seasons of
promise which starts November 15 so if
you log on to our web site
www.kpbs.org/news/evening edition
[Music]
and earn and create this amazing thing
not only for my family but for my
friends and eventually then I would make
impact on the world this was pre all the
things that have happened to me some nor
was there an audience nor was there
money but what became very clear to me
was oh my god I could be giving all
along the way and so if you're watching
right now and the only thing you can
give is following pencils of promise on
Instagram
well that matters to us yes your
eyeballs may mean something one day oh
great
and by the way $7 matters like if that's
what you can give and I think you know
listen we live you know most of the
people watching right now which is thank
God live in abundance like there is a
complete misunderstanding what happens
when you live in a world where you can
afford a five dollar eighty five cent
coffee every day you're watching on your
smartphone with very much and so you
know I think there's a lot of people
watching who don't know what it feels
like to donate for the first time just
ten dollars I don't think they
understand the high some might not
some may go to the pencils of promise
right now donate ten bucks and be like
Gary was wrong right no value but I
think for a lot of people they would be
blown away by the actual feeling and so
it's not about the size it's about you
actually have empathy and compassion for
other human beings and I think this is
something we need to be pushing now more
than ever you know I was thinking about
the number of schools that I mentioned
do you do you guys have any sense from
those first schools that you open
because you said it is Basic Education
reading and writing how some of those
kids that that that started in these
first schools are doing now and the
impact that you've had on not just them
but the communities well we have a
number of students that we track now
that we've hit a 10-year mark we had our
birthday birthday on October 31st happy
birthday thank you you have a number of
kids that are now in secondary school so
we're gonna have an opportunity to
really see that impact the continuity of
that impact if you will over the course
of the last ten years we've had
innovative programming we have a digital
easier program so children in Ghana have
access to culturally appropriate
age-appropriate reading at their
fingertips right so much impact II Gary
for you and I said it sort of jokingly
but I think spare time and when you have
the ability to do something like this of
all the things you have your hands and
obviously this is different than your
business course what's the most
anything for you Mac in a macro in any
yeah anything that you're that you've
got your hands in really right now
prioritization you know you know when
you're when you're just doing a lot of
things when you have a family when you
have ambitions when you have
responsibilities of nine hundred
employees when you sit on boards when
you when you want to feel good before
your last breath there's a level of
excitement I'm actually not anxious of
it you know I don't judge myself I know
what my intent is and I'm trying to do
good in all facets and so it's just one
big game of juggling and I think the
best jugglers she or he are capable of
understanding that some of the balloons
some of the bowling pins hit the ground
and that's okay because the net is I'm
holding up eight hundred balls and if
thirty seven fall I have to go and spend
some time to apologize right but in
reality I still have seven hundred
seventy balls going in the air I think
that that is um I think of life as a net
game and so the biggest challenge is
just scratching the itch or putting the
hole in the you know the rest of the
league at the time and and and I think
if you're capable of not judging
yourself and leaning into what your
intent of that process is versus where
you perfect at it you can get into a
very happy place
give up on perfect it's the same idea as
you're saying instead of having to give
a hundred dollars give $10 $11 it makes
sense for god you said it was the Jets
that brought you joy and I love this in
reading about you you want to own the
Jets badly yeah I was I was born in the
Soviet Union
I came to America when I moved to Edison
New Jersey a bunch of boys outside were
playing football it was clearly the
thing that made me welcomed because I
wanted to play to and the Jets in 1982
really represented a very big thing to
me I haven't missed a snap of a New York
Jets game since 1982 I'm talking and
it's not easy as a Lions fan even I know
and this is not DVR stuff this is when
it's been braids I'm watching so it's a
big passion and you know I've come to
realize just back because we've talked a
lot about like life yeah it's an
escapism for me it's the one place where
all the other important stuff that I
spend ninety nine percent of my time on
for those three hours I don't care about
anything
well I appreciate the time from both
thank you so much thank you we just want
to let people know if you want to get
involved for pencils of promise and I
know you mentioned this you can visit
pencils of promise org thank you Carrie
go now